[Music]
breaking down a new barrier when it
comes to arming Ukraine the UK has
donated long-range missiles in defiance
of concern about Russia's response this
old promotion video giving a sense of
the weapons impact the use of Storm
Shadow will allow Ukraine to push back
Russian forces based within Ukrainian
Sovereign territory the defense
secretary told MPS the UK's modern
missiles are being fitted to Ukraine's
old aircraft a difficult and
time-consuming task I'm not going to
comment on when we expect these to be
used but nevertheless they have yet to
be tested and and we will soon find out
Storm Shadow is a Precision guided
cruise missile launch from the air it
carries a warhead weighing up to a
thousand pounds is five meters in length
and can hit a Target at a range of more
than 155 miles
the weapon is powerful enough to punch
through reinforced concrete and could be
used to hit underground bunkers command
headquarters and weapon supplies
a Ukrainian military Source said to me
this decision by the UK could be a game
changer he said the Russians had learned
to move their weapon stores and command
posts out of the range of the Rockets
the ukrainians have but these new
missiles will give Ukraine the ability
to strike much deeper into russian-held
territory even in theory as far as the
bridge that connects the captured
Crimean Peninsula with Russia
the British move prompted a menacing
message from Moscow
on the front line though the UK's
missiles will be a big boost for Ukraine
as the fighting grinds on ahead of an
expected counter-offensive officials
hope other allies will follow suit
this is not the first time when UK takes
a lead on life or death decisions for
Ukraine and then the rest follows we
have seen it since the beginning of the
full-scale invasion the UK has fired
Storm Shadow missiles multiple times
against its enemies these typhoon Jets
were preparing to hit Islamic State
Targets in the Middle East
attaching the weapons to Ukrainian
aircraft is a whole new level of risk
but also potentially reward
debraham Sky News